vous c'était un marin le marin avait vu un
vendeur de Libanais pensé que je pouvais la
sauver lui sauver l'innocence du nœud de la
cause il n'a jamais connu la liberté et puis
avec le diable il s'est tenu toute une vie
sans un acre et aide ou assistance
elle était un  veuve elle n'a jamais quitté la maison
avant sept heures huit et un elle a regardé par
la fenêtre elle a réussi à crabber pour
ne jamais se sentir jouer pour la mort de son
mari ou morte dans une flamme par la maison
de la rivière de la nous sommes restées à une
distance raisonnable toute la  les enfants
jouent dans le quartier tous les
enfants jouent
que vous voudriez inventer pour
le cuir chaque fois qu'ils se battaient tôt
ils avaient l'un l'autre il lui a apporté des
fleurs une chair et les panas elle n'a pas
répondu et il a attendu des heures jusqu'à ce qu'elle
accepté de lui offrir un petit whisky dans un
terrible whisky qu'elle avait pendant un moment
que vous dormiez tous les matins pour le
petit déjeuner à l'intérieur depuis le mois de
décembre, ils avaient l'habitude de tango jumping
parade jusqu'à ce que mon petit mouvement convainc
de  Fargo boire du citron n'a pas été maladroitement
arrêté et elle l'a embrassé au revoir et a
assisté au rivage et elle a allumé un grand
feu comme jamais auparavant près de la maison de
la rivière
tous les enfants jouent
tous les enfants tous se sont réunis et
quartier tous les  les enfants jouent
autour
des enfants elle les sermonnait pour le
cuir vivaient était une bataille bidon
qu'ils avaient l'un l'autre
elle était de nouveau veuve elle n'a jamais quitté la
maison avant sept huit et un elle a
regardé par la fenêtre elle a réussi à pleurer
mais à ne jamais sentir le but  pour la mort de
son mari ou mort dans une flamme près de la
maison de la rivière bien qu'il soit resté
à une distance raisonnable
tous les enfants jouent autour du
quartier tous les enfants jouent
autour
tous se sont réunis et tous les enfants
jouent
tous les enfants jouent autour de
la  église dont tu aimes te souvenir le
lépreux
était ouvertement meilleur qu'elle avait avec toi
quand je travaillais